I wonder found some numbers so I am I
just moved up the most you know I went
to this I literally now this is just a
pretty standard five minute video and
you can't see the numbers that are
important but first thing I want to
point out two years five minutes 16
seconds you may want to jot that down
because that's gonna be important I'll
jump down a second to but you might as
well try to undo so five minutes 16
seconds that's how long this video is
now down beneath here this is okay kiri
this what you've got is a whole bunch of
quality I don't worry about writing
these numbers now the important ones
I'll write down myself but the important
thing I want you'll notice is as the
quality increases unsurprisingly the
file size also increasing this makes
sense okay so let's go right to the top
you can see there let's write this down
if you download consider 5 minutes 16
music when you drop this down below okay
so this this particular video in 1080p
is and the number this is quoting for us
is one hundred forty four point seven
megabytes if you're curious about what
1080p means for now you just need to
know it's a kind of high definition okay
so it'll look good on your iPhone okay
now here's my question to you and it's
quite easy to work out based on this
work we've done how long is it gonna
take to download okay you hit it on
YouTube your app starts loading in it
okay how long to download now you've
already done the work to convert this
into megabytes per second and this is in
megabytes right so if you have this
number I mean 1.54 I have approximate it
maybe you have the exact there but we're
getting pretty close right so the
download time in seconds is gonna be
make
/ megabytes per second right there's
your amount of visual great okay someone
write that down 140 140 4.7 divided by
1.5 by the way you wanna be really clear
about this you go back what I said that
units here an elective thing you can
actually include the unit's here too
this is the size so it's megabytes right
this is the speed so it's megabytes per
second now just have a look at what
happens to the it is just watch what
happens to use megabytes what's gonna
happen to that it cancels cuz it's on
the top of the bottom
what second what's gonna happen to that
look what's gonna happen your this is
this symbol means division right you're
dividing by a fraction right if I told
you hey what's 3 divided by 1/2 you
would I mean you can't tell me what the
answer is but you would probably turn
that to multiplication and flip the
fraction upside down what do you do
because there are 603 yes so what's
happening here
you're dividing by a fraction so
therefore this second is going to come
back out of the top as it should because
your time I'm going to suggest a minute
a half is fine because what is it that
I'm downloading in you I'm downloading
five minute and 16 seconds video so this
is quite fine for me right this is that
caching bar it just goes straight across
and my video plays just fine okay okay
but but as we know this isn't in fact
this is a very very ambitious number I
would say we're actually much closer to
what Nick suggests is before okay and
sometimes not even that if you're out in
for Jane and you're in a lot of people
and they play pick'm will go well
whatever it is okay so let's just
consider okay I said eternity hates this
okay at this speed this is how long to
download
so I'm gonna maybe want to modify this a
little bit okay the P doesn't stay for
people it stands for something else now
that's how it's download at this speed
so now I'm going to pose the question to
you what if a whole bunch of people get
on the network right and instead of this
speed what you get is it grinds to a
halt and you get this okay now it's
funny that I say saint-- grind to a halt
because it's absolutely stupid leaf are
still considering that like it's like
getting things from the air like
seriously it's just doing this thing and
you don't even have to worry about how
that happens now how am I gonna work out
the time this time what I'm gonna do
what did we do the fault what did we do
before yeah I had to do this conversion
right this conversion turned it into
megabytes per second right and that was
really good for me so can you go ahead
take this 3.2 instead of 13 right
multiply by a million divided by it you
can do actually several these at the
same time if you like so just one two
three four steps that'll get you to
megabytes per second once you've got
that number can someone tell me to two
decimal places
zero point all right so now I've got a
new demo to you now I did I should have
a new download time right how many
seconds do 386 okay now wait that long
this is a long time but in particular
it's a problem because 380 seconds by
the way if you can't remember that you
can do this just take these numbers in
your calculator screen divide that by 60
and then go ahead and hit your degrees
minutes seconds button and that'll tell
you how many minutes and how many
seconds right how many minutes six
minutes so this is a problem so what
does your phone do in this situation no
option what is it you play if your phone
and YouTube are doing their jobs though
it doesn't like instead it says oh
you're downloading is too slow to get
this version right so it says that's
okay I have plenty of other versions
available I'll just stop getting this
one and I'm just other downloading this
one now it's it's still like
high-definition 720p it'll still look
good on my phone cuz my friend is small
okay but it's like half the size it's
less gone oh it's slightly more than
half the size okay so that's what I'll
do and that's why sometimes you'll
notice your video skips a little bit and
the quality changes it's because this is
happening